todos los ejemplos que hemos visto sobre
espejos parabólicos hasta el momento han
sido cóncavos
con cabos
y esto significa y probablemente ustedes
ya sepan pero de todas maneras lo voy a
mencionar son aquellos cuya abertura se
dirige hacia nosotros o se abre hacia
donde se forman las imágenes más o menos
así
aquí nos interesa lo que está dentro del
espejo la superficie interna la forma en
la que yo recuerdo que estos son
cóncavos es que el cabo me recuerda la
palabra acabar como si tomara una pala e
hiciera un hoyo o un hueco quedando esta
forma hicimos muchos ejemplos usando el
punto focal el eje principal el punto
focal punto focal y representamos
objetos con las flechas y analizamos
cómo se refleja la luz en el espejo al
pasar por los puntos focales recordamos
que tomamos un punto de aquí emanaba un
rayo de luz paralelo al eje éste pasaba
por el punto focal
y otro rayo de luz que pasa por el punto
focal y se refleja de manera paralela
quedando estos elementos hicimos muchos
ejemplos de esto en el último par de
vídeos lo que quiero hacer ahora es un
breve ejemplo sobre cómo usar un espejo
parabólico convexo lo escribimos aquí
con sexo
convexo en donde nos interesa el otro
lado del espejo la parte de afuera por
decirlo de alguna manera del tazón nos
interesa esta parte de aquí
aquí también dibujamos su eje principal
su línea de simetría este también tiene
su foco acá su punto focal
pero ahora asumimos que la superficie
reflejantes se encuentra de este otro
lado en esta parte de acá
la superficie reflejante pensamos que
sucede si yo pongo un objeto aquí en
frente del espejo qué va a pasar con la
luz pero no hacer el mismo ejercicio
asumimos que este objeto va a estar
iluminado por alguna fuente de luz que
no sabemos dónde está y podemos tomar
cualquier punto de luz sobre el objeto
pero por conveniencia nos acostumbramos
a tomar el punto de luz que emerge de
acá y dibujamos nuestro rayo de luz que
sale paralelo al eje principal y no
vamos a ver la matemática involucrada
aquí pero a reflejarse en esta parte
exterior se va a orientar el reflejo
como si viniera de este punto focal como
si viniera de este punto focal así que
se va a reflejar así y si ahora tenemos
otro rayo que parte de este mismo punto
y se dirige al punto focal
así pues se va a reflejar de manera
paralela al eje aunque aquí va a chocar
con el objeto pero bueno se va a
reflejar así
qué tipo de imagen se va a formar bueno
éstos dos rayos nunca van a converger
pero dará la impresión de que ambos
divergen o salen de un mismo punto
detrás del espejo extendemos este rayo
acá y nos va a dar la impresión de que
ambos rayos salen de este punto de acá
así que vamos a tener una imagen virtual
que se va a ver más o menos así
si tomáramos otro punto del objeto por
ejemplo en la base la luz pasaría por
acá se reflejaría y daría la impresión
de que este rayo de luz proviene hacia
acá por lo que aquí es donde daría la
impresión de que surge este punto
lo que quiero que aprendan en este vídeo
es que cuando tratamos con espejos
parabólicos convexos en donde la parte
exterior es la parte refrescante no
vamos a tener una imagen real vamos a
tener una imagen virtual
imagen imagen
virtual
virtual que va a ser más pequeña
pequeña que la imagen del objeto
original
y ustedes encontrarán ese tipo de
espejos por todas partes especialmente
en donde hay esquinas que pasan autos
por ejemplo esta es una esquina más o
menos así y es probable que la entrada o
salida de algún estacionamiento ustedes
se encuentren este tipo como de espejos
convexos
se deja la luz de todas direcciones
estos espejos también están en los
pasillos de las tiendas para que los
encargados puedan vigilar lo que ocurre
en esos pasillos
y espero que hayan encontrado esto muy
interesante